[Música]
a
escala en parís
braulio more
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
escala en parís un programa de radio
france internacional en colaboración con
la televisión france24 og en español
francia históricamente ha mantenido
relaciones muy estrechas con américa
latina y el caribe la presencia de
guadalupe y martinica en el caribe y
sobre todo de la guyana que hace
frontera con brasil y surinam planteando
una serie de problemas de estrategia y
de seguridad para el gobierno francés en
esa zona para hablarnos de este tema
saludamos aquí en nuestros estudios
liz guitton directora de la dirección
general de relaciones internacionales y
de estrategia de las fuerzas armadas
francesas bienvenida a este escala en
parís alice grito muy buenos días señor
moro es un placer para mí de estar
compartiendo un momento con usted sobre
para presentar las acciones del
ministerio de las fuerzas armadas sobre
el continente de latinoamérica y el
caribe
gracias por haber aceptado nuestra
invitación a liz hilton desde el 2018
ocupó usted este cargo precisamente de
directora de la dirección general de
relaciones internacionales y de
estrategia cuál es el papel que juegan
las fuerzas armadas francesas en américa
latina' pues la misión principal de mi
dirección general es de preparar el
contexto general en el cual involucramos
hoy en día especialmente preparar los
libros de defensa estratégicos que
priorizan a nuestros esfuerzos de
defensa y también a proponer una
prospectiva estratégica sobre los
asuntos mayores y proponer
recomendaciones en cuanto a las
respuestas los instrumentos necesarios
para
enfrentar enfrentar los diferentes
desafíos que emergen en este sentido
cuáles son las prioridades hoy que
tienen precisamente en la dirección que
usted encabeza con respecto a américa
latina con respecto a américa latina por
supuesto tenemos relaciones muy
estrechas con numerosos países y sobre
todo porque somos simplemente una nación
de este continente con un millón de
ciudadanos franceses también 4.000
militares franceses que actúan en esta
región para proteger nuestros intereses
y también desarrollar la cooperación de
defensa lo que significa es que además
de que tenemos asuntos prioritarios como
por ejemplo la protección de nuestro
centro de espacial
único que tenemos en esta región es otro
mundo de kurú y también la frontera más
larga que francia tiene en el mundo es
en américa latina la compartimos con
brasil 7
a 700 km
juntos y
somos vecinos pero también desarrollamos
colaboraciones muy estrechas en los en
los foros multilaterales y bilaterales
hay una cosa que es poco conocida de
nuestro público el hecho de que existan
precisamente guadalupe martinica y la
guayana supone para el gobierno francés
proteger más de 220.000 kilómetros de
zona económica exclusiva es decir casi
la mitad del territorio francés tal como
se le conoce hoy en día esto supone como
usted menciona una serie de
colaboraciones de aporta aproximaciones
con los gobiernos de la región al
instituto por supuesto porque tenemos
fuerzas de soberanía del del pacífico'
que están encargada precisamente con la
protección de estas zonas de nuestros
territorios ultramar es y también de
manejar a través de ejercicios de
vigilancia de seguridad marítima pero
también compartir ciertos de los
desafíos con los cuales están
enfrentados los países vecinos como los
tráficos ilegal es la explotación de
recursos de las riquezas naturales y
también a asegurar que la pesca ilegal
no prospera así que estamos vigilantes
en cuanto a la evolución de estas
tendencias y manejarla
la posibilidad de desarrollar
cooperación es por ejemplo con columbia
república dominicana o dominica cuando
se necesita además de que por supuesto
en esta parte del mundo los tres los
eventos climáticos se ven cada día más
importantes y traumáticos y por eso
necesitamos coordinar las respuestas y
lo hacemos también con los eeuu pero
también países de europa como el reino
unido y holanda
que tienen también territorios en esta
región y lo hacemos en el marco de la
iniciativa europea de intervención a
usted de bocado una serie de temas
importantes por ejemplo el problema del
cambio climático el problema de la sobre
explotación de recursos naturales esto
es lo que lleva a que en el ministerio
de las fuerzas armadas francesas esté en
proceso de creación este observatorio
estratégico de los países
latinoamericanos y del caribe y
eventualmente
absolutamente y de veras necesitamos más
análisis más claves de lectura también
informar a nuestras autoridades
políticas sobre la manera en que la
región está en evolución especialmente
después de la pandemia
y asuntos como tal como las inversiones
extranjeras a las de por ejemplo china
rusa oa otros países que están
interesándose en las riquezas naturales
de este continente pero también a tratar
de anticipar lo que puede suceder en el
futuro lo que necesita hacer en trozos
de investigación mayores y es por eso
que es un honor para mí
de poder
establecer este observatorio que es
completamente nuevo que empezará su
trabajo al final de este mes y que
durará por tres años y exactamente cómo
va a funcionar como operar yo sé que por
ejemplo existe ya un observatorio
político para américa latina y el caribe
que promueve el centro de estudios y
relaciones internacionales de ciencias
políticas puedo entender que este
observatorio que ustedes están creando
es un poco diferente cuáles serán las
funciones que va a tener este
observatorio estratégico para los países
latinoamericanos y del caribe a mismito
para decirlo sencillamente
será un espacio de reflexión estratégica
involucrando
investigadores franceses y
latinoamericanos los dos entre los
papales
[Música]
manejando también una visión completa de
los asuntos de seguridad en
latinoamérica de relaciones de defensas
entre los países de américa latina y
francia y también en europa segundo
proporcionará al ministerio de fuerzas
armadas a análisis y claves de
comprensión de esas devoluciones y pero
también al tercero objetivo es por
supuesto de contribuir al desarrollo más
amplio de la investigación académica en
el ajenos ámbitos de la defensa y de los
estudios latinoamericanos en francia así
que espero que a través de este
observatorio tendremos más ante sesión
política también sobre la evolución de
esta región hacia usted de referencia
hace unos instantes al tema por ejemplo
de la pandemia
recordemos américa la tiene el caribe
son más de 600 millones de habitantes al
mismo tiempo es una región que ha sido
duramente golpeada por el coronavirus
ahora mismo la región del caribe en los
departamentos de guadalupe y martinica
hay protestas en este terreno como ve el
ministerio de las fuerzas armadas este
enorme desafío que implica esta enorme
pandemia que afecta a todo el mundo
claro está pero en particular
por supuesto a la pandemia golpeó
américa latina tal como el resto de este
mundo y vemos que los niveles de pobreza
las debilidades estructurales sociales
económicas de los países de
latinoamérica han sido exacerbada por la
pandemia necesitamos desarrollar
respuestas colectivas
creo que las actividades criminales ha
dado por razón de la evolución negativa
a razón de esta pandemia necesitan
esfuerzos comunes creo que trabajar
sobre asuntos estructurales tales como
desigualdades y luchar contra el trabajo
informal a la corrupción a manejar a lo
mejor acciones también del sistema de
salud público y
hacerlo en una de tal manera que sea en
el respecto de la soberanía de cada país
aparece muy importante por supuesto la
situación en guadalupe martinica nos
preocupa mucho
y de nuevo le puedo asegurar que lo
hacemos respondemos a esa situación con
y la cooperación de los países vecinos
también hay muchos desafíos usted lo
comentaba está por ejemplo el tema del
narcotráfico está el problema de la
seguridad en general está el problema de
la sobreexplotación el problema que se
presenta con el agua va a ser la guerra
de este siglo en muchos países al mismo
tiempo hablaba usted del tema de las
influencias es el caso de rusia es el
caso de china poco se habla de la
influencia que está ganando de israel en
américa la tiene que es bastante
importante de manera muy resumida porque
el tiempo se nos acaba al dígito cómo
aprecian ustedes este movimiento de
influencias de grandes potencias en
américa latina' quien por qué significa
esto para francia es un cambio mayor en
las relaciones estratégicas mundiales y
creo que la presencia rusa o israelí es
más es más focalizada sobre temas
específicos lo que se destaca más
hoy es la de china no tan solo porque la
confrontación estratégica con los eeuu
puede ser observada a través del mundo
entero pero también porque los recursos
los instrumentos utilizados por china
para intentar acceder a recursos
riquezas
acceso a
expone los países concernidos a riesgo
de dependencias y también de reducir la
autonomía política estratégica de cuáles
países cuando necesitan desarrollar su
país así que estamos por supuesto a muy
vigilante a esas inversiones extranjeras
creo que es el asunto de este mundo del
mundo actual
riesgos de escalada horizontal son
numerosos por eso el observatorio de
nuevo será un instrumento mayor para
intentar
a comprender mejor estas evoluciones
comentaba usted francia tiene su mayor
frontera a nivel internacional en
américa latina es la frontera entre la
guyana y brasil precisamente es una
región donde frecuentemente se escucha
hablar de los problemas por ejemplo de
explotación desmesurada del oro violando
todas las que son las normas
internacionales
contaminando la tierra
el observatorio como podrá jugar en este
terreno habrá una colaboración
particular con brasil yo sé que el
gobierno francés tiene una relación
estratégica un acuerdo estratégico con
el gobierno de brasil y con el gobierno
de méxico pero en este caso en concreto
como jugaría esta situación pues creo
que por lo que me con que me impacta
directamente
tenemos un diálogo estratégico con
brasil que es muy importante muy muy
avanzado y cooperamos en muchas áreas e
incluso a tecnológico a económico pero
también de defensa y a este nivel el
observatorio servirá
a proponer a potenciales
áreas complementarias de cooperación
creo que será interesante a focalizarnos
sobre los desafíos de mineral
de ahorro pero también asegurar que a
[Música]
hagamos todo lo que es necesario incluso
incluso en el sistema de naciones unidas
para desarrollar respuestas regionales
que garanticen la paz y la seguridad
regional así que hay otro tema que es
fundamental que es clave que es el tema
de la migración y del tráfico de
personas de seres humanos que se está
desarrollando bastante en esa región
como ve el ministerio de las fuerzas
armadas francesas esta problemática creo
que es una problemática que nos afecta a
todos en europa pero también en américa
latina cuando miro a la situación en
américa central del problema de
migraciones
va emergiendo y creo que necesitará de
nuevo a poner en marcha a soluciones que
cuentan con la cooperación de todos los
países concertados pero también que
respetan el derecho internacional a una
de las tendencias actuales
debilidad del sistema de la arquitectura
de seguridad internacional y creo que
los países de latinoamérica son
particularmente involucrado en intentar
a ofrecer soluciones malicia de gritón
directora de la dirección general de
relaciones internacionales y de
estrategia del ministerio de las fuerzas
armadas francesas gracias por haber
asistido a esta escala en parís muy
amable por su presencia a ustedes les
damos una nueva cita en la próxima
semana
aquí en otra escala en parís
[Música]